The joe rogan experience.
You can ask anybody who goes to like China driving over there is crazy.
They have lights but they don't follow them.
They're like Christmas ornaments,
traffic lights.
They're just over there blinking and no one's following them.
When you see the two red lines,
here's the crazy thing,
right?
You want to make a left hand turn in China,
you don't make it from the left hand side.
You come all the way from the right and you turn over there.
Why don't,
I don't know why.
It's two weirdest thing I've ever seen them.
I'm one does it that way.
Yeah,
because that's how they do it over there.
Wait a minute.
They don't ever turn left from the left lane from the right and you're over
here.
You turn way over there.
Can we find evidence of this online?
Google that I have.
Everything I say I know will be instantly googled.
Uh,
but yeah man,
it's crazy.
Me and Steve Byrne,
we screamed like little girls at least 13,
two times on the ride home.
It is scary.
Here's the thing.
Didn't see one traffic accident,
not one over there.
And the bulk of the country drives on the right.
Oh,
okay.
I think there's some confusion here.
Well,
I don't know what the confusion is.
I did it.
I think,
um,
some of the country in China drives on the right,
but some drives in the left.
So maybe that's where the,
the,
the issue is.
Does that make sense to people?
Drive on the right side and half the people don't want he telling you,
man,
slow down dude.
They just go right in to the,
they just go right in to the lane.
What are we watching?
Accidents.
This is Chinese trafficked.
Oh,
I don't want to say Chinese traffic cause you know someone's going to get run
over.
There was some horrible shit that I saw online of.
Oh Shit.
Oh fuck dude.
On a motorcycle.
They nail people.
But see that's what they do.
They just drive through.
Don't give a shit.
There's no rule.
This,
this is nuts.
Oh my God,
You know what?
I hate seeing stereotypes played out right before my fucking eyes.
Look.
But where are the Chinese Nascar drivers?
Oh my God.
He just nailed an old lady on her bike.
These people are fucking crazy.
I'm telling you,
man,
you scream like a little girl like drive.
Look at this video.
This is crazy.
These people are in the rain with the shitty cars and they just drive in through
intersections.
I hate saying this because I know on it would,
I don't want to believe in stereotypes.
Oh Jesus.
Oh,
hit by a bike and the other guy runs over him and then keeps going.
They don't care,
dude.
There's a billion of them all.
Oh my God.
Look at this guy trying to make it across.
This is insane.
This guy cannot do this.
He must back up and rethink and get a helicopter.
That's the only way he's getting across that lane.
People are fucking nuts,
man.
They don't care.
I don't like watching this.
This is giving me mad anxiety.
Can you imagine?
Oh Jesus Christ.
He's kind of motorcycle.
Oh,
he judged one and then got nailed by another.
Do that all day,
man.
The fact that those guys are stopped is amazing.
It just like they,
we vote Jesus,
look at this.
Oh Jesus,
Boom.
Oh my God,
these people on Bikes are insane.
They're trying to cross the traffic.
They just say,
ready,
go.
Their streets must just be like egg drop soup everywhere.
Just brain.
You know what they saying?
A lot of it has to do with the Chinese culture and the way they interact with
people.
They mind their own business.
They don't look to the left into the right.
They just keep,
keep straight.
And because of that,
they're,
they're socially,
this is explained to me by a Chinese man that the,
the,
the way they're socially,
um,
sort of a groom to interact with people and walking.
Cause there's so many people,
you bump into people all the time that they've sort of taking this and then
drive.
They drive with the same mentality.
They go with the exact opposite of what you're supposed to do.
Okay.